[Música]
é eu sou um diretor de televisão no
brasil televisão aberta e nos últimos 27
anos
é eu venho me dedicando basicamente duas
coisas de um lado entretenimento de
massa e do outro lado ação social e é
meio chato isso porque as pessoas acham
que essas áreas não são amigas
é eu estou aqui hoje para tentar provar
pra vocês que essas áreas
elas são amigas mas elas deveriam ser
mais ainda porque elas têm muito a
ganhar e por que elas têm coisas em
comum
então basicamente a idéia é essa porque
comunicação entretenimento de massa e
ação social é tem afinidade por que as
duas tem um cliente em comum que é a
multidão
o entretenimento de massa ele encontra
sua vocação quando ele justamente
atingir a multidão só que ele chama isso
de audiência e ação social ela também
encontra sua razão de ser
quando ela alcança a sociedade
então são nomes diferentes para a mesma
coisa é e aí eu vou eu vou fazer uma
provocação para vocês aqui a fingir que
eu sou um publicitário coisa que eu não
sou
está até parecendo o publicitário
paulista mas eu não sou é e eu teria que
vender aqui hoje um produto e esse
produto é um mundo melhor
a primeira coisa que eu teria que fazer
é fazer uma pesquisa para saber se vai
ter saída então vou fazer aqui uma
pesquisa com vocês se eu tivesse uma
banquinha de fora a de chamar a atenção
para uma coisa eu não tô querendo vender
um produto chamado mundo melhor
eu tô querendo vender a coisa mesmo um
planeta mais legal para todo mundo não é
só o nome tá então se eu tivesse uma
banquinha de fora e tentar vender pra
vocês quem é que estaria disposta com
para mundo melhor ele fora depois da
palestra
aqui é um pouco pegava convertidos né
mas é eu arriscaria a dizer que eu já
fiz essa pesquisa em muitos anos
conversando com as pessoas ea verdade é
que todo mundo quer um mundo melhor
é um mundo melhor têm uma saída enorme
todo mundo que é e eu arriscaria mais um
pouco eu diria que quase ninguém fora os
fundamentalistas radicais
quase ninguém se opõe que o mundo melhor
seja algo compartilhado por todo mundo
independente de credo de raça e de
gênero
e aí você falou é se todo mundo quer um
melhor porque o mundo melhor não tá
bombando aí nas prateleiras na vida das
pessoas
é uma coisa estranha e eu tenho uma
teoria sobre isso
a impressão que eu tenho é que as
pessoas não sabem exatamente o que fazer
para promover um mundo melhor com
exceção de vocês aqui hoje depois de
tantas palestras mas as pessoas lá fora
elas querem mas elas têm dificuldade e
isso acontece porque porque está todo
mundo muito atarefada com suas próprias
vidas
não está fácil de dizer os assuntos
individuais a sobrevivência do mna nossa
pauta os assuntos coletivos ficam em
segundo plano e eu acho isso legítimo a
gente não pode apontar o dedo que as
pessoas também acontece o que as pessoas
estão vivendo um misto de de medo com
uma certa sensação de impotência e isso
também é legítimo
apesar de ser bastante triste e aí
existe um certo quarto um certo quadro
bem desanimador para quem está tentando
vender
lembra que eu sou publicitário e eu
estou tentando vender um mundo melhor
mas diante desse quadro desanimador
eu queria chamar a atenção para uma
coisa as pessoas não estão levantando do
sofá para comprar um mundo melhor
mas elas continuam consumindo uma outra
coisa que é o entretenimento
então algo existe no entretenimento que
faz com que as pessoas
se movimenta em direção a ele ea minha
teoria é que essas esse intercâmbio de
técnicas pode ser produtivo os dois
lados
alguém vai dizer que as pessoas buscam
entretenimento por uma certa alienação
eu acho que pode até ser mas eu acho que
fundamentalmente não é por causa disso
eu acho que desde o tempo das cavernas
o ser humano gosta de histórias
histórias
a gente continua consumindo na internet
netflix porta dos fundos
o instagram facebook a gente teve que
desligar o celular para assistir àquela
outra palestra e aí eu vou lembrar de um
caso mais recente de entretenimento que
carregou consigo valores que a gente
considera valores para um mundo melhor
por exemplo o filme black panther
quase todo mundo aqui viu sim mas mesmo
assim eu vou falar sobre alguns valores
quanto era negra aqui no brasil era
negra o que é um filme com protagonistas
negros quer dizer mais que isso é muito
melhor que o som é um filme com 98% eu
acho que mais que isso inclusive 99,9
por cento do elenco negro com
personagens negros com complexidade
subjetividade inteligentes e bonitos
tudo que a gente costuma ver só em
personagens brancos né normose e aí mais
que isso esse filme consegue ser o filme
americano de super herói mais visto em
todas as épocas
esse filme superou o homem aranha e
super homem de ferro que são produções
absolutamente milionárias
então isso quer dizer alguma coisa esse
filme ele conseguiu arrecadar no mundo
1.2 bilhão bilhões de dólares
isso é muito dinheiro mas mais que isso
isso é o dobro do que a campanha do
obama conseguiu com doações
individuais na reeleição e olha que o
obama é o meia é o case é o político
mais bem sucedido na história da
política americana e doações
isso é muita coisa então as pessoas se
mobilizaram para ver um herói negro
muito mais do que pra ver um outro
revela também que obama é vamos lembrar
o seguinte um filme passa em duas horas
o governo demora quatro anos merecia até
muito mais investimento em uma outra
história que eu gosto de contar uma
história que eu tenho uma pequena com
uma pequena contribuição eu dei dez anos
aliás acho que 12 13 é a aula de roteiro
na cidade de deus que é periferia do rio
de janeiro oeste uma uma organização
chamada central única das favelas eu
ensinava técnicas de roteiro para a dona
de casa para anotar do jogo do bicho
para estudantes para qualquer pessoa que
se inscrever se no curso
a minha ideia que na verdade é a minha
ideia só colaborei com isso mas a idéia
da organização era que a gente estava
ajudando essas pessoas a contarem suas
próprias histórias
isso é fundamental porque o seu
protagonismo na verdade com esses cursos
a gente acabou plantando a semente de um
filme que logo depois surgiu o chamado
cinco vezes favela agora por eles mesmos
pra quem não sabe essa história é
importante saber o filme que eu
colaborei e se chama cinco vezes favela
agora por nós mesmos porque porque em
1960 existe um filme chamado a cinco
vezes favela
esse filme era de cinco universitários
na zona sul do rio de janeiro brancos
que bem intencionados estavam relatando
a sua visão sobre esse território
chamado favela
só que seis décadas depois a realidade
social à realidade tecnológica
barateamento de equipamentos
possibilitou que a favela pudesse falar
por ela mesma
e aí a gente colocou um tijolinho nisso
e esse filme cinco vezes favela agora
por nós mesmos virou o primeiro longa
metragem brasileiro completamente
concebido
roteirizado e dirigido os jovens de
periferia do rio de janeiro isso é um
entretenimento com causa
nos estados unidos as pessoas vão
chamando isso de entretenimento change
entendimento com causa com propósito e é
por isso que estou falando da união
dessas duas coisas
existe um outro caso muito bacana eu
gosto muito dessa história que é o
desafio do balde de gelo para quem não
estava no planeta terra 2014 é merece
ser explicado é é uma brincadeira que as
pessoas passaram a fazer jogar água
gelada água com gelo balde de gelo na
cabeça na própria cabeça é uma coisa que
a pessoa deve fazer mas adora ver os
outros fazendo e tem algo de
entretenimento é e tudo isso estava isso
era engraçado isso era legal mas isso
estava isso é uma campanha de doação
para conseguir fundos para uma
organização americana chamada a ls que
busca justamente apoiar pessoas que têm
uma esclerose que tem uma sigla chamado
ela é ali a rara
falta dinheiro para investimento nas
pesquisas e 440 milhões de pessoas
fizeram vídeos e com o compartilharam
rios
isso rendeu 220 milhões de dólares para
esta organização
puxa que legal quanto dinheiro parte
desse dinheiro foi direcionado para as
pesquisas foi para a escola de medicina
da universidade de massachusetts que
conseguiu encontrar um gene que abriu a
possibilidade para novos tratamentos
para essa doença
e tudo isso tem a ver com o fato do
homer simpson e do cristiano ronaldo que
compartilhem compartilhado um vídeo
jogando um balde de gelo na cabeça
então percebe como essas coisas podem
colaborar mais as ações sociais eo
entretenimento
a ação social não precisa ser
necessariamente sisuda um papo sério uma
coisa de gente iniciada
mas enfim alguém pode virar e falou
assim poxa mas você está falando só
sobre dinheiro
isso não tem nada a ver com consciência
não tem nada a ver com mudança de
comportamento
ok mas é pra falar sobre mudança de
comportamento talvez a gente tem que
entender melhor como funciona o cérebro
eu não sou neurocientista mas não
pesquisar profundamente na equipe disse
e eu descobrir que eu pesquisei
profundamente na equipe boa e eu
descobrir que o lado esquerdo do cérebro
é ele o paa é é um ministério dedicado a
atividades lógica das informações e o
lado direito do cérebro é o hemisfério
que cuida mais da parte intuitiva parte
emotiva parte criativa e
fundamentalmente ele que organiza em
forma de de percepção ele organiza o
sentido das percepções
eu posso ter errado qual é a atribuição
do lado mas isso não importa
pelo seguinte o que eu estou querendo
dizer é que quando você quer mexer com o
comportamento de alguém não adianta você
usar exclusivamente argumentos racionais
você precisa emocionar as pessoas para
que você consiga mexer completamente com
alguém e aí pra causar um certo efeito e
provar que eu to falando eu faço essa
pergunta vocês acham realmente que as
pessoas não usam camisinha porque elas
nunca tiveram contato com uma campanha
que fala use camisinha
as pessoas gostam muito dinheiro com
campanhas que dizem use camisinha
é lógico que isso não é verdade é
evidente que as pessoas quando não usam
camisinha é que elas não foram
capturadas com o argumento que seja mais
profundo engajamento girls óbvio então
não adianta isso
por outro lado e por outro lado não eu
fico só pensando o seguinte vamos
lembrar por exemplo
jovem de 16 anos quando você vir e falar
pra ele uma frase um imperativo
use camisinha o que você acha que esses
jovens fãs
agora eu não vou usar só de sacanagem
porque eu não admito ordens para cima de
mim
ao mesmo tempo nos anos 80 existe um
programa no cassino do chacrinha que
tinha uma marchinha muito simpática que
dizia bota a camisinha bota meu amor
hoje está chovendo não vai fazer calor
uma coisa muito simplória muito
simpática e que adianta é e que entra no
comportamento das pessoas de uma forma
criar um certo repertório de solução
quando você está entre quatro paredes
o humor é uma coisa é uma estratégia de
entretenimento que ajuda a resolver
certas situações
então o entretenimento sim ajuda a mudar
comportamento como por exemplo está
acontecendo mais recentemente nas
novelas turcas
não sei se vocês sabem mas a turquia é
hoje a maior concorrente da tv globo no
mercado mundial de venda de novelas são
novelas extremamente bem feitas
com elenco de primeira grandes atores
alta produção e são novelas radicalmente
feministas são novelas que em poderão a
narrativa feminina além de também criar
um novo arquétipo do homem romântico
para o mundo árabe
mas o que importa são narrativas
feministas que estão sendo vendidas para
todo mundo árabe
o mundo árabe inteiro está consumindo as
novas turmas e isso está sendo
responsável favor profunda essa
informação depois na internet em sites
confiáveis é isso está sendo responsável
por um reposicionamento feminino no
mundo árabe e denúncias mulheres saindo
do silêncio e denunciando assédios e
casos de estupro em todo o mundo a então
o entretenimento quando é conciliado com
a ação social ele muda sim o
comportamento e eu não estou aqui só
dando um recado para o entretenimento eu
também gostaria que as pessoas que
formulam a política pública
considerassem a possibilidade de colocar
estratégias de comunicação
estruturalmente em seus pensamentos de
política pública mais para finalizar eu
tenho uma certa autocrítica eu acho que
eu errei aqui com vocês porque eu fiquei
só falando coisas do lado esquerdo do
cérebro estratégias racionais na verdade
é eu acho que deveria ter vestido lindo
vestido de mini on com um certo número
de sapateado divertido pra vocês é mas
eu acho que vocês já são pessoas que já
são realmente convertidas em relação às
coisas que eu falei eu só prova que não
chamar a atenção para algumas coisas e
eu queria finalizar é com a frase de um
poeta que eu admiro muito o poeta
muçulmano
admiro tanto que inclusive coloquei no
meu filho meu filho do ranking bem esse
cara ele sintetizou 14 minutos numa
frase só lhe digo o seguinte se você
realmente quiser ser revolucionário de
vida às crianças
[Aplausos]